tonight lebanon has been knocked into
darkness again the country has two power
stations one in the north and one in the
south they don't have enough fuel to
keep running so there is no electricity
the only light in beirut is from the
headlamps of cars
it's costing me it's increasing it now
costs between 800 000 to a million lira
to run a generator every month petrol is
now more expensive and it's going to
cost more in the future if that's what
happens we'll have to stop paying for
the generator and i'll stop working
they've destroyed our lives
even before this the state power company
was only providing three or four hours
of electricity a day
those who can afford it have their own
generators but for everyone fuel is hard
to get
in july we filmed petrol cues miles long
snaking around beirut
the financial crisis is so bad that the
world bank has compared lebanon's
hyperinflation to weimar germany and
zimbabwe
in my view the electricity had already
stopped in the country we never had
proper electricity in this country
they're laughing at us now they've
stopped it completely because they're
trying to humiliate the people
that's how people are living now we're
being humiliated humiliated with a lack
of petrol bread electricity and this
should be our right
the government says it will get power
back up and running again in days it had
better the security situation is
relatively stable for now but the
people's patience will eventually run
out alistar uncle sky news